Hello, and welcome to this course on FBX data ingestion for Unreal Engine version 5.6.
My name is Alex Coulomb, I'm an Unreal Engine authorized instructor, course author, and
I run the XR Creative Studio Agile Lens immersive design.
In this course series, we'll be looking at static mesh ingestion using the FBX file format.
For our agenda, we'll begin with the simplest way to import FBX files and other assets,
which is actually to use FAB, taking data from the cloud.
Then as we consider bringing our own assets from our DCC tools into Unreal Engine, we'll
begin to explore a number of considerations, such as units and scale, naming conventions,
how to combine objects, setting up material IDs, and looking at pivot points, which can
be changed both in the DCC tool and in Unreal Engine.
From there, we'll look at triangle count, both an LOD level of detail approach, as well
as nanite.
After that, we'll explore adjusting assets in Unreal Engine using the modeling tools,
considerations for UVs, especially when baking lightmaps, setting up collisions, best practices
for importing skeletal meshes, and then we'll wrap up with some future considerations for
your FBX workflow.
In the next video, we'll look at how to import FAB assets from the cloud.